[Music]
businesses of all sizes are continuing
to feel the wrath of the pandemic as
positions are left empty forcing them to
close their doors at least temporarily
victoria saha live just off the strip
with a look at the staffing shortage
ahead of new year's eve celebrations
victoria
denise lowry's would be getting ready
for a big weekend but instead they put
up this sign closing their doors because
they didn't have enough stuff to cater
to diners
the doors for larry's prime rib closed
wednesday and won't open up until the
first week of 2022. the last thing we
want to do is is keep the team in place
on a
you know on a skeleton crew and people
not have a good dining experience about
four of their kitchen staff tested
positive for covid making it hard to
even offer to go options and with new
year's eve so close the business will
take a hit we're waiting on results from
test all the rest of it so we're at a
point where we just can't run
the operation lowry's isn't alone the
seats at crepe station over on jones and
lake mead will sit empty for nearly a
month as owner william tejeda finds more
workers we're like facing a hard time
this location is their newest one
business was booming but there wasn't
enough staff to keep up on a good day
they would have 10 workers now they're
down to four i know it's not the best
decision but you know at least we're
going to have time
to hire more people and then we can come
back stronger than before some experts
say the staffing issue may be serving as
a lesson to business owners it was burn
and churn people were disposable because
you always hire someone new and now
people are seeing the importance of
retention versus recruitment so i think
it's a good thing for the industry
there are other businesses announcing
temporary closures grits cafe and
downtown sorry good pie in downtown las
vegas also announcing that they will be
closing temporarily reporting near the
strip tonight victoria saha live local
now victoria